i got kidnapped by my family
to celebrate
[Music]
i'm getting married gwen stefani is a
gorgeous bride to be
the 51 year old singer who is set to wed
blake shelton this summer was showered
with love on thursday
as her family gathered together for an
intimate bridal party
i'm getting married gwen took to
instagram to share some fun behind the
scenes videos and pics of the
celebration
zooming in on some decor like these
gorgeous pink and orange roses writing
feeling loved feeling blessed it's one
of those once in a lifetime
you know moments she also revealed some
of her gifts including a heartfelt card
that included
something old a copy of the masked
booklet from her parents wedding back in
1966.
oh my god are you are your eyes watery
yes
blake and gwen got engaged in october
2020
and have been together since 2015. both
of our lives have basically
fallen completely apart and uh
and little did we know it happened to
both of us at the same time
and uh we bonded over that and then
you know it's so somewhere in in that
you know that
time of of just you know darkness
was this ended up being
the greatest moment of my life you know
so it's just it's amazing it truly is
and the pair has never been shy about
sharing details about their big day
this is where we really get down to the
good stuff last month
blake revealed the first song he and
gwen plan to dance to as husband and
wife
on the tonight show starring jimmy
fallon if you leave uh from the pretty
and pink soundtrack
that's not true at all or i i swear i
have it right here
uh we talked about this we both love the
song
we're both fans of the 80s why not why
not jimmy
i love it
and back in april gwen told seth meyers
on his show late night that their
wedding will be very low-key
very simple really simple the guest list
will not have a lot of musicians it's
going to be like my mom and my dad
like just literally going to be just
family
and um we are looking forward to that
though it's gonna be fun we're gonna
make it really fun but it's not gonna be
a big
like you know it's not like the queen
and king are getting married or
something but during a march appearance
on today with hoda and jenna blake said
otherwise
revealing there might be guest
performances including
former voice coach miley cyrus and
bestie adam levine
you know it's starting to sound like a
coachella
lineup here all of a sudden i've got all
these superstars saying they're gonna do
it
i'd love to to be able to take everybody
up on their offer and have this
amazing concert wedding as for current
voice coach nick jonas well
he might be part of that lineup too
here's what the singer told et last
month
it's gonna be a fun night i'm sure there
will be lots of wonderful beverages
uh in involved and i'm i'm so happy for
them i wish them all the best and if you
tried to recruit you as the
entertainment or maybe you and your
brothers would you say yes
very expensive like i said we are very
expensive so blake
you know we gotta dish it out